c'est par un tweet que le secrétaire
général de l'onu a annoncé son arrivée à
kiev ce mercredi au lendemain de sa
rencontre avec vladimir poutine je suis
arrivé en ukraine après avoir visité
moscou nous allons poursuivre notre
travail pour étendre l'aide humanitaire
et assurer l'évacuation des civils des
zones de conflits plus vite cette guerre
prendra fin mieux ce sera pour le bien
de l'ukraine de la russie et du monde
entier
principal objectif donc de la visite
d'antonio guterres s organiser avec les
autorités ukrainiennes des couloirs
humanitaires depuis les zones de guerre
et surtout permettre l'évacuation des
quelques 1000 civils piégés dans
l'usinage of talent à marioupol une
évacuation que le chef de l'onu voudrait
voir se réaliser ce vendredi les
conditions doivent être réunies pour que
nous le fassions cela me complique c'est
une opération très compliquée au boot
inn a donné son accord de principe
il a été convenu que les détails
seraient discutées lors des réunions qui
sont en train de se dérouler
au programme également pour antonio
guterres est ce un déplacement ce jeudi
dans les communes de bourreau janka de
boudhha et dire pin en périphérie de
kiev trois villes théâtre d'exactions
pendant l'occupation russe en mars l'onu
mène d'ailleurs une enquête sur les
actions commises abuja qui pourraient
relever de crimes de guerre si beaucoup
d'habitants sont encore coincés sous les
bombes le nombre d'ukrainiens qui fuient
le pays continue d'augmenter
selon les nations unies ce chiffre
pourrait atteindre les 8,3 millions de
réfugiés contre un peu plus de 5
millions actuellement une situation qui
oblige le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
a demandé
1,85 milliard de dollars de l'argent
nécessaire pour soutenir ses actions et
celle de ses partenaires en faveur des
ukrainiens qui ont quitté le pays